[Musique]
puisque matthieu delormeau à vous avez
perdu à paris la semaine dernière et
hier soir vous êtes donc allés passer
une nuit avec daniel daniel qui est là
daniel moreau ça fait combien d'années
que vous n'aviez pas dormi avec la gare
son récit la réponse il ya eu des gains
la deuxième guerre mondiale je pouvais
mais un peu sérieux deux secondes très
très très longtemps et combien ça se
chiffre en année et en disant ouais à
peu près moi ça fait ça faisait dix ans
que vous n'aviez pas dormi avec un
garçon j'ai pris et avec et mannequin
attente trois ans on rappelle à nos
téléspectateurs que vous êtes une
nouvelle recrue que vous habitez avec
votre maman est là voilà que vous n'avez
jamais connu garçons je suis ici mais je
des couches plus depuis longtemps vous
avez connu un ou deux garçons c'est ça
et il ya très longtemps
ouais voilà et dormeur là mais vous avez
passé mais c'est vrai j'avais passé la
nuit avec matthieu delormeau
on va voir ça dans un instant on attend
tous avec impatience à ce que la nuit
que daniel avec mathieu je peux vous
dire
c'était chaud très chaud à c'était plus
haute
tweetez plus dogues on sait qu'à 50
nuance degré qui est sorti avec la
nouvelle version est bien
matthieu delormeau et daniel ont passé
une nuit en chambre matthieu delormeau
ça faisait comme maintenant vous n'avez
pas passé une nuit avec une dame hinda
17 ans de 17 heures et vous ai semé
pendant le chiffre exact
maintenant honnêtement non mais c est ça
doit être à peu près on était un peu en
réalité on savait pas les bras pas un
peu c'est peut-être vous étiez peut-être
déjà ensemble on s'est pas reconnue tant
par l'hyper ne s'était pas de gaieté de
coeur on est pas on va voir
on va voir ce qui s'est passé cette nuit
là je n'ai pas vu des images 50 nuance
deux de leurs maux
[Applaudissements]
dieu
[Musique]
une chanson facile facile ça fait 30 ans
que j'attends ce moment je crois pas
qu'il viendra t on fait quoi ce sont
prévues quoi tu dis n'est pas loin 30
euros j'aime mieux un petit chèque coeur
de protéger tous je préfère payer 60
euros
alors tu en sais comment tu agis
maintenant temps que mon appel non
khadr le tunisien je suis fait tabasser
bien été changé tu t'es démaquiller
aussi à non si on pourrait peut-être
faire le calumet de l'amour beaucoup
trop dangereux oublie le grand duc à
moustache dont la moustache tu es malade
réservé à béni snassen exclu
ce soir je vais encore distribuer du
donneur
j'ai un beau signe à sochaux tu
directement une quitte là bas je reviens
j'en ai pour deux heures doha dans deux
heures alors à mathieu
scorpion vous aurez une sexualité
débridée ou cours mathieu je suis
ça fait du bien de voir tout ça ça et
franchement et mathieu faut que vous
précisiez un truc pour la maman de
daniel danseurs évoluent à votre maman
qui nous a demandé de préciser quelque
chose ce soir mathieu est ce que c'est
un droit que la prod m'a appelé deux
fois pour dire tu précises bien bien
bien que tu n'as pas fait l'amour avec
dans cette région de thies demande de
préciser je pouvais y avait un doute du
fait que c'est une très jolie femme mais
voilà donc je précise pour la maman de
daniel et les par son prénom
jocelyne je suis sur un nuage aussi si
tu nous regardes ils n'ont rien fait
voilà non on va n'a pas fait l'amour
ensemble on se contentait de quelques
caresses haddaoui quelques moments de
tendresse mais s'il est pourquoi elle
voulait pas qu'il fasse l'amour si on
espère la garantie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui je trouvais beaucoup de choses il
n'y a pas de suite
alain alors attendez mais je vais leur
demander parce qu'à mon avis c'est
peut-être mal mais on va reculer les
images qui avait des trucs chaud non
mais non mais non on va voir ça oui moi
ce que j'ai découvert c'est que mathieu
est un hyperactif parce que vous avez il
part comme ça bon c'est pas de sa faute
il aurait bien aimé rester mais il est
obligé de partir il a été hyper actifs
sauf avec moi là bas jusque là il perd
passif mais c'est surtout qui en fait on
dirait comme ça que j'ai pris un râteau
énorme même pas un râteau la cabane du
jardinier entier mais c'est que c'est un
garçon délicat ils disaient que je ne
couche pas le premier soir
dans le cas cité du coup j'ai raison
[Applaudissements]